اختبار اخر للقوات والعتاد قبل التوجه الى
جبهه القتال
ما هي الا ساعات معدودات حتى يكون هؤلاء
في الخط الاول للجبهه في حرب يقولون ان
مصير بلدهم
يتوقف عليها
اشاركوا في الحرب لاجل السلام حتى لا يعيش
احفاد الحرب في المستقبل وهذا دين على كل
رجل اي يدافع عن بلده واتمنى ان يقف حمام
الدم هذا وتنتهي الحرب
والى جبهات القتال عن الجبهه
اثر الحرب بديه للعيان ومسيره لا تغيب عن
الاجواء هذه اثاره هجوم قبل وصولنا الى
هذا المكان بلحظات
هنا نقطه التماس الاخيره تبدو مدينه ارضيه
بمنطقتها الصناعيه على مرمى حجر من القوات
الروسيه لكنها لا تزال عصيه على السقوط
وهذا هو حال جبهه الوسط باتجاه مارينكا
حيث كل طرف يحافظ على مواقعه وفي اتجاه
جبهه الشمال فالمبادره للقوات الروسيه
باتجاه خركيف اما المبادره فهي للقوات
الاوكرانيه في جبهه الجنوب والقوات
الروسيه تتبع خطط الصد
تتغير خطط الحرب الروسيه وحتى الاوكرانيه
لكن لا حديث عن حسم للمعارك على الاقل
حاليا
مناطق التماس متوتره على كل الاتجاهات
لكننا ننفذ المهام المطلوبه منا بشكل جيد
توجد صعوبات نحاول تجاوزها واما تهويل
الاعلامي الاوكراني بشان العمليات المضاده
فلم يكن سوى بروباجندا ولم نرى منها شيئا
على الارض
[موسيقى]
بين الاحراش الممتده من
مارينجا تتخذ الدبابات وقوه المدفاعيه
مواقعها ونرصد في هذا المكان توجيه نيران
المدفعيتها الى مواقع عسكريه اوكرانيه
حددت احداثياتها سابقا
وهذه الوحدات تدمير مواقع عسكريه ومنع اي
تقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه مواقع
متقدمه للقوات الروسيه
هي معركه حاميه الواطيسي ما بين القوات
الروسيه
والاوكرانيه على امتداد الجبهات من
من الشمالي الى الجنوب وكل طرف يريد ان
يكسب المزيد من المساحات
لتحقيق النصر الذي يريده
الجزيره جبهه الوسط